this is a production of Cornell
University
so I think Adrian actually did a really
nice job introducing what my group does
um just to put it in in my own more
mechanical engineering perspective
um so we're all about connecting
structure to function in polymers uh
originally that was mostly looking at
mechanical properties so like my
absolute favorite thing to do is pension
tests which is pulling something until
it fails
um it's been my favorite since since
undergrad
um and uh but but we um
do lots of other types of things to try
to understand polymers so
um addition text not just picture
testing we do a lot of other types of
experiments my core trading is really
continual mechanics which is what I hope
like a thermodynamically consistent
framework to describe materials and
where their properties are governed by
and we also have diverged into many
other type techniques like we actually
make our own polymers and we also run
atomistic simulation so we're kind of
like whatever we need to do to answer
the question that we hear about that's
that's what my lab does
um and I'm going to talk today a lot
about our work that's at the
um tailoring at the atomic scale or at
the molecular scale but we also do work
where the structure that we're
interested in controlling is sort of
tens or hundreds of nanometers or
micrometers or even even millimeter
scales so um we're I guess size scale
agnostic although I found it pretty work
fun working with chemistry and chemist
and I hope I will find the same thing
for biology although I'm a little bit
intimidated by how uncontrolled biology
is
to be honest about that okay
so I'm going to talk today first about
the engineered living materials
Institute and then about some of our own
research and please if you have
questions feel free to interrupt me I
definitely don't care whether I make it
through all the slides I'd rather you
you understand me and be excited about
what I'm talking about
all right so engineered living materials
is a field that involves materials that
either are living used to be living or
were made by living materials some
people will Define it only as the first
one but I I like this more inclusive
definition and the engineering part for
us uh means we're not this like growing
a tree and letting it grow however
um we were trying to manipulate it to
serve the function that we wanted to
serve and so that could be a synthetic
biology type engineering so kinetic
engineering it could be
um growing different organisms together
so that they have feedback on each other
or it could be
um like engineering sort of synthetic
inputs to the system to manipulate uh
growth and function and
um lots of reasons I'm excited about
this uh the main one that I see I guess
we need two is that the way that we are
like have our society right now is not
very sustainable I'm sure I'm not the
only person in this room who thinks that
and especially if you look at our civil
infrastructure right now it's starting
to fall apart it's actually survived
like way longer than it was designed for
but still it's falling apart we want to
replace those those structure that's a
huge greenhouse gas emission it's also a
huge like Financial cost and as they
crumble and fall they're not like being
reused for something right so that's all
waste product
um and so my idea is can we use biology
not just my idea if many people have
this idea right can we use uh what
biology is great at to
um like do things better the second time
around to perhaps repair the existing
things
um I'm I'm a polymer person so I
reluctantly put the second dramatic
bullet point up here
um but that is this a fun fact from a
doe report that uh we're supposed to end
up with like more plastic masks than
fish fish in the ocean by 2050 and I'm
sure like you've all seen the horrifying
Gatherings of plastic in the ocean which
is only really the surface problem
um and so a lot of the materials that
we're working with including my favorite
polymers
um they they end up as waste products
and so there's tons of like disposable
consumable Polymer Products that we
could maybe think about replacing with
things that are not disposable and
consumable or if they are disposed uh
you know degrade in a in a more friendly
manner
so this was the first part like let's
think about doing things better on Earth
than the second part way Adrian
mentioned is
um also as we move to
um building habitats like on the moon
and on Mars like we need to also think
strategically about how we're doing that
and so you know NASA and space force are
both really pushing for this further um
building permanent habitats
um and if you're going to do something
like that you need to minimize the mass
you are bringing with you and use
Institute resources
um and you also want to take techniques
bring to bring materials that
um have adaptable function so if I could
bring like life-wise bacteria or spores
right or seeds with me and then grow
them on demand into what I need that's
much more flexible than like I don't
know bringing a house that I assemble
and then it just is a house and it's
always a house and if I didn't remember
to bring my microwave I'm in trouble
probably I'm not bringing a microwave
but like you want to I have a set of
materials or set of tools where you can
make what you need what you need as you
need it and recycle it and make it into
something else the second time
I'm using the word recycle but don't
picture the current recycling plants
where we don't actually use them
um yeah everything just gets stored in a
in a building and never actually
recycled
and the the last piece of this
um that I'm really excited about is
enhancing the functionality of materials
you know I think
this is something that a from a
synthetic material perspective we've
been working towards but traditionally
like we make a structural a structure
around us it serves a mechanical
function maybe it also serves a thermal
insulation function but we want to have
materials that convert energy protect us
from uh cold weather when it's cold or
back so that it doesn't protect us from
cold weather when it's not cold right
and that
um
serve many many purposes at once and I
think that's something that biology is
very good at and I'm sure
who know that better than I do
so uh because of all those things
um I've been working on on building this
engineered living material
s
our goal is basic science and technology
development and as we were discussing
this over the last year I think we
realized education also needs to be a
central part of this because we need to
build the team of people who can
actually work on this and there's a lot
of uh language to overcome but to even
have a conversation about about science
that crosses
um biology and engineering and social
science
um and so as I think Adrian the same
phrase I did so we're interested in
materials built of and or by engineered
non mammalian living organisms and I'm
really emphasized saying this is not a
biomedical type effort this is a like
all the world around us type effort and
we're focused on
um thinking about like wearable
technologies that are sort of for the
individual uh building
um habitats say we're controlling the
environment in a lava tube on Mars so
that's now breathable and
um and and thinking about how do we
build new colonies either
um on Earth in places that were
previously not habitable
um or
um uh in in space and the reason we're
doing this here is because Cordell has
like all of the expertise we need to
take on this Challenge and there's so
many like awesome young faculty working
in synthetic biology and uh really great
expertise in planned biology and
microbiology and like yeast right like
we and we have like great Material
Science and mechanical engineering and
electrical engineering and like you just
need to bring it together so you are
excited about changing the world
I don't know everybody should say about
chicken in the world if you're excited
about changing the world in this way
um could uh do I not join our team so
this is these were our founding members
that have been meeting over the last uh
mostly since January but a little bit
last fall as well to build this Vision
together
um and of course I highlighted uh Laura
Maria and
plant people
okay
um so if you're interested please send
me an email or you could join our uh
Journal Club
Trevor is leading next week one of our
only postdocs
um we could help you with a postdoc
Fellowship application one of Cornell's
sources or external and um if you think
like you have a research project that's
interested I'd like love to work with
you or or talk to you about other people
that would like to work with you or if
you're interested in getting all
um we're definitely aggressively ready
proposals so
um yeah
do people want to ask questions about
this or
they teach us in our teaching
engineering classes that were supposed
to wait an awkward amount of time before
we move on but my reach it
okay yes I've reached it
all right I'm so I'm gonna talk about
something
um
oh hopefully more tangible
um which is a work for my own group I
tried to pick out two like sub projects
that
I think you'll appreciate but I'll find
out all right so the first is looking at
uh Force sensitive molecules that we've
been
um looking at these as a way to probe
courses in polymer to try to understand
better what's going on within polymers
I'm going to talk about our works
especially on glassy polymers which is
are like acrylic or or uh polycarbonate
like safety safety glass type materials
um because there's a lot less known
about those
um scientifically
and uh this is mostly going to show the
work of my PhD student Stephen Yang a
former post and former post office
Lab at in Cornell's chemistry Department
he's such a phenomenal polymer chemist
um and the uh Charles thies and Decker
bet the technion we actually post off
together
um also a phenomenal campus I've been
really lucky to have some great
chemistry collaborators
okay
so when I think about mechano chemistry
or these are really we call these
mechanopores molecules where the
chemistry is driven by mechanics
I like to uh draw the like classic
school this High School right energy
diagram
but okay I've lost track of when you
learn things so if I think about
um this molecule I think about like a
reactant and a product and usually if I
want to go from a reactant to a product
I give it like heat or maybe I have a
light driven reaction
um but in this sense in this in this
system we're looking at using mechanics
to drive from
um a closed state to an open state or
basically I'm using Force to break a
bond
hopefully there's something very
intuitive about using Force to break a
bond uh in this mechanochemistry field
where like you make it on purpose not
just accurately breaking things and
hopefully to add functionality to our
materials so
um in most of these systems when we
apply Force we are lowering the energy
barrier to get to the open State and
we're also Shifting the equilibrium so
the open state is is preferred
um and so you can think about this in
equilibrium States you can think about
these in terms of reaction coordinates
and this field started um really
thinking about covalent bonds and weak
covalent bonds
um but there's sort of a broader
interpretation now of using more Dynamic
bonding if you go all the way down to
sort of lower hydrogen bonding and
unlike Van Der waals interactions the it
sort of loses its meaning because these
are so Dynamic that your [ __ ] in
equilibrium that you get from having
poor supplied is not terribly impactful
so we're typically up at sort of
stronger binding energy
and
um
the first like really big paper in this
field is out of the 100 material systems
group at Illinois and they use this
really cool mechanical four called spot
brand it actually came from
um transition lens technology so this is
a molecule that is known to be uh
light responsive but what they found is
that if you attach your meccano4 or your
molecule
um to your to a polymer chain on at the
proper side sites basically you want to
go across this molecule what you could
do is uh break this this carbon oxygen
Bond and you get a different form of the
molecule that is now colored and
fluorescent and what color it turns into
depends on on what polymer you put it
into but like purple if you see anything
purple red or uh blue on this screen
that's that's the molecule changing and
they put this originally into into two
polymers one elastomeric like rubber
band type material and one one glassy
material
um and so this is
um the active system where this is
properly connected and this is a control
system where it's not properly connected
it's just polymathacrylate which is that
very stretchy especially if you pull
slowly
um so here you can see this like as
they're pulling so they're going to a
strain of hand which means 10 times
longer than it was originally
11 times longer
um and so this is very stretchy and when
you go all that way you start to
actually activate this molecule because
you are putting enough Force across it
to break this Bond and then when you
um when this material fails it recovers
it's actually a nice dark red because
now it has
less area but this is the idea
um I actually saw this presented twice
in grad school but the first one was
very early on the second time I was like
anyway to graduate and I was like I need
to go model this so I got myself a post
about Fellowship so I could work with
this Reuben on this but I just thought
this was like such an awesome technique
um
there's been a ton of work on other
mechanical force since then and also
I'll kind of work with people putting
our brand into like every polymer
imaginable
um so I I originally made like several
slides of this and then cut down to just
one
um so this is uh a light emitting
molecule this is out of uh rinse the
Bismuth group einhoven and what's nice
about this is
um so when it breaks it emits light
which means you have like an
instantaneous measure of force on the
polymer chains as opposed to the spiral
it's more of like an accumulative
measure
um but this one is non-reversible so
once it breaks you're like separated and
you're you're done
um and uh this this third one is like a
there's many versions of it but this is
out of uh Stephen Craig's group down at
Duke and they started by doing this
conversion that gives you a longer
polymer chain so you're like um wrapping
this to give you more length and so if
you put lots of those along a polymer
you can have a huge amount of like
stress relief so you're like pulling
something and it's gonna break and then
instead of the whole thing breaking it
like gradually unfolds so I always think
of this as like the the type of the
synthetic polymer world
the right Community to talk about Titan
crap
you guys should learn about Titan
it's a it's like it's a muscle protein
that uh has this really cool like
sacrificial bond breaking in on full
days you can like stretch it like insane
amounts and
um
it's
okay that's too human
so
um so they did this thing with unfolding
but then they also were able to actually
drive crosslinking so this becomes a
reactive site and if you put a
cross-legger in there you can
um actually end up with a material
that's like stiffer and tougher than you
started with so you do what seems to be
destroying the material you end up with
something better
uh this is a system that I collaborated
on uh right around when I was starting
here
um with a group that's a like by a
somewhere between biology and chemistry
and Material Science and in this system
we're using disulfide bonds which are
like a pretty weak covalent bond and
reversible Bond
um so we're we're breaking those by
doing uh compression on these polymers
and
um what that does is give you a open
site open reactive site so that this
doesn't have a direct visual cue unless
you you tag it with a fluorescent Marco
so in this first system we're we're
doing like compression for some amount
of time and then you have like a thiol
reaction that happens and you can look
at fluorescence intensity you get a
sense of how many of these disulfide
bombs are broken
um and then they're actually able to use
that
um to control stem cell growth so
um time all stem cell growth
um this is if you don't apply any force
of polymer this is if you apply Force
for uh 30 minutes and then you do a
separate growth step this is using App
related fibronectin to make the
connection between the disulfide and
stem cell growth so you could do like
pretty pretty cool functional things as
well you don't have to just do color
change in color emission
okay so
um as I mentioned I was really
interested I guess I feel like I'm
really interested in using this as a way
to understand glassy polymers better
and glassy polymers have this or sort of
this awkward material that's like stuck
not in equilibrium so it's like always
trying to find a more comfortable state
but it like never gets there
um and so we're using the spa param
molecule and uh previously a group that
I postdoc with had done origin uh we
wanted to do a series of tension
compression and this is partially to
address that at the time like a
misconception in the field that you
could only activate these molecules in
tension if you're like a polymer
mechanics person or really a mechanic
person
um the way that we think about tension
and compression is actually sort of like
a rotated cancerous recipe
um so I was pretty convinced that they
should translate pretty well between
touching compression and we want to show
that experimentally
um
so this is our typical experimental
setup that we do so we're doing uh
tension testing at the same time we're
monitoring the fluorescence so we do
that exciting with a 532 nanometer laser
and then we filter out uh the laser
light and all the noise in the lab and
just get the wavelength that we're
interested in and we get a full Field
image of our material the thing that
looks black is because that doesn't have
the molecule in it nothing on the right
thing is the glassy polymer whisk bar
print in there
and um
I'm going to show a lot of stress during
curves
what I've learned over the last years
that I need to Define stress and strain
okay so stress for us is mechanical
stress it's Force normalized per unit
area in this all the tests I'm going to
show so it's
how much are you pulling but we need to
normalize by area because otherwise
something much larger obviously gives
you much more Force than something
that's tiny
strain here is change in length over
initial length so it's how far are you
pulling so how hard is it to pull on the
y-axis and how far are you pulling on
the x-axis so
um
this is a pretty typical glassy polymer
curve what you have is an initial linear
elastic regime you go through this thing
called the yield where stuff starts
flowing and then
um
you might be able to keep pulling this
is PMA at 90 degrees C so you can keep
pulling here but if we're at room
temperature it would have broken before
we even hit yield
um so our having the spiral brand in
there is that small enough percentage is
that it has no effect on the stress
screen response that's what the top
curve is showing on the bottom we see
the fluorescence response so just PMA
has no change
um as expected and then what we
typically see in glassy systems is that
you get a response as you start going
through yield so once you get blowing up
this polymer you start to see this
molecule open up and so it's helping us
like understand what's going on in the
material
this is our attention versus compression
experiment so tension on top compression
on the bottom these are slightly
different axes but basically the shape
so the curves look very similar
compression typically has a higher
stress associated with so it's harder to
to push something than to pull something
um and it it goes at slightly higher
strains
um and the fluorescence looks very
similar for both tension compression as
well we're doing this at three different
strain rates
um
I want a one to warm up the idea of
strain rate here uh because it's going
to become important later but
um basically if you pull faster
that means you have a stronger polymer
response but it also tends to be more
brittle because things don't have so
much time to like slide and relax so
they just break instead
um and it also um fluorescence means
you'll have a actually less responses
even though the force is higher you have
a lot less time
okay so the comparison we're really
trying to get it is pension versus
compression and so we analyze this data
in terms of looking at when does yield
happen so what's that Peak and then when
does the fluorescence start to kick off
so we're looking at actually a change in
slope there
and what we found is that this
fluorescence activation which is the
open symbols always follows yield
so it's always happening after yield and
that also tension is always happening
the core compression yeah yeah
um there's a bunch of ways but I'm I'm
taking this P Point here so it's the
peak of the stress training curve
that's actually a like a very subtle
debated Point
um
but yes
okay
and then
um so it looks here that compression
happens after attention but if we
collapse this data down into thinking
about
um what is the tension actually in the
plane so we're compressing this way but
if we look at what's happening in the
plane of the material we actually get
the data to collapse down so it's like
even though we're pushing the molecules
are feeling pulling
uh in the transverse Direction
and and that's right because this spot
red is acting as a molecular level
sensor
um all right let's give that
okay
so all of that data was on pmma or
acrylic which I mean it's a nice
material it's transparent people use it
it's good for fish tanks but it's never
been my favorite
uh my favorite material
is polycarbonate
probably if anybody who's ever taking a
class for me knows because I like to
share with my favorite material is I
don't that's probably a strange thing
okay so polycarbonate is awesome it is
also transparent not quite as
transparent as acrylic but it's a really
tough polymer so unlike Pima Bay where
if I pull it at room temperature it
breaks
um I can I can pull polycarbonate quite
a lot before it fails and I from
basically the first time I saw this fire
brand thing I thought we should put it
in polycarbonate because polycarbonate
is like a much better model glassy
polymer and I can run tests at room
temperature
that's nice as an experimentalist
because I don't have Reflections off the
window of my thermal chamber
um but it's also nice because I don't
have temperature dependence of this
molecule opening and closing these
temperature effects that connect so the
molecule and I wanted to like get rid of
that
so I I had actually asked if we could do
this while I was post-offei but they
said no but like five years later
finally had the right the right people
um to be able to do the synthesis
um because the previous experiment we
were following somebody else's synthesis
here we had to come up with our own
this is not one of my students who first
presented this you use this video and I
don't know
okay
okay so
um
we had to figure out how to make this
polymer and they're on the one hand it
was like very straightforward on the
other hand it was very challenging I
would be able to highlight a little bit
about that
um and so the one I think that's nice is
we get to put different functionalities
into our polymer so
um this is actually a much easier to
make molecule and not just because our
collaborator sent it to us but also
because the separation is much simpler
to get much higher yield than in our our
previous version we've used for PMA
um and so this is our mechanical core
and we're reacting it with bisphenol a
polycarbonate which is like your
standard polycarbonate uh the one first
thing that's maybe hard about this isn't
when you do this commercially use soft
tune which is like a good way to kill a
grad student
um but uh you can use triposity and
stuff like a relatively simple switch as
long as you work in a hood
um and um so it like on paper looks
straightforward and I would say even
before we started jeffcoats predicted
the exact problem we ended up having
um which well this is our failed
material where it doesn't change color
which is that
um we want to grow polymer off of uh the
side so we want to react uh
polycarbonate right with the smart Paran
um but what happens is that this
molecule is switching between the
spiropen and marathyanine state and we
actually end up growing polymer off of
uh one of the open sites from that
reaction and so
um to control that what we do is well we
tried a bunch of things we ended up
doing that with successful was we
basically
um limit the reaction by limiting
um how much fashion there is and so
um by using excess BPA relative to
phosgene we basically make only the most
selective reaction happening so it's
preferential to grow the chain this this
side chain thing that makes our marrow
signing inactive or brand inactive is
like less favored so we basically go
really slowly
deeply
um and and build our polymer chain that
way
okay and then the the second sort of fun
challenge here was it turns out usually
in uh industry and made polycarbonate
through
um thermal past light by heating it up
and making a material but if you do that
it'll mess with your um the kind of
chemically active component here because
again our molecules are temperature
sensitive so we had a solvent cast so my
my student actually dug up like a 1960s
Japanese patent that figured out how to
like solvent path without getting
crystallinity in the polycarbonate so
that's that's what this setup is here
pretty sure that's you know like just a
metal ring but it made things work
um just one step above duct tape and and
we're able to get like a functional
material
and now we can run tests at room
temperature my student also upgraded our
setup with my shutters um but basically
we get very similar Behavior to what we
saw in the in the PMA system but now
we're able to do it with polycarbonate
which is a much better material and much
more useful from like a
being damage resistant perspective
one thing that's really cool about these
glassy systems is that
um if you trigger this this color change
it actually stays so the molecule itself
will want to reverse if you just put it
in something that's like very compliant
but the the glassy Matrix is actually
like stuck in this in this open State
and it'll it'll stay there it's actually
a really cool
study that's just out on on archive like
looking at how you can use a spiral
brand to study residual stress and
polymers or like what the stress that
gets locked into the polymer when you do
processing which is a huge concern for
light fatigue and failure I'm going to
show you a little bit about how we try
to use this molecule to understand
um sort of plasticity and fatigue in
glossy polymers
foreign
okay so we ran this uh test at four
different strain rates so now we're
doing four Decades of strain rate this
is actually not a very rate sensitive
polymer which is one of the things I
like about it and so these four stress
trading curves look almost identical if
you go faster it's a little bit stiffer
oh it's a little bit stronger
if we look at the fluorescence change
and get the same thing we saw in the PMA
system which is the slower you go
the more fluorescence you get
as a function of strain but if we flip
this around
and do this as a function of time we can
see here really that this is a question
of kinetics so our fastest test has the
least amount of time
and but it actually right starts
fluorescing well before all the other
ones
so this is all at uh room temperature
and we're going slow enough that we
shouldn't be like eating as we pull or
something like that yeah
yeah
okay
this is the slide of my second favorite
test after a unique axial pulling the
failure
I like to do cyclic testing because you
can really learn a lot about a material
by loading it and unloading it uh for
example if I stretch a rubber band right
I could I can load it and unload it lots
of times and it should follow basically
the same herb always like come come back
and forth in glassy polymers what you'll
see is you have something called
uh plastic deformation or permanent
deformation so as you as you load more
times either if you go to the same
strain your stress will decrease or if
you go to the same stress you'll get
further and further and this is like
part of how materials fail and if I just
pull I really don't know anything about
whether things were privileged or not
but if I unload then I can figure out
like did I dissipate energy did I
accumulate permanent damage did I
accumulate a permanent stretch so this
is a test of three Cycles
uh to the same strain and then we go to
a higher strain and then a higher strain
and so in terms of stress we get this
initial yield behavior and then what
looks like kind of kind of linear
behavior on this plot and in terms of
fluorescence overall we see a build up
in the fluorescence response but
um much less during these Cycles than
during the initial step to each cycle
we match that to a stress relaxation
test so in a stress relaxation test You
Pull and then you you hang out there so
you don't move anymore but your stress
will tend to decrease which is why we
call it relaxation so it takes less
Force to keep holding at the same strain
or the same displacement
and we ran these two tests because we
want to have two different loading
histories that take the same amount of
time so we match the time for this
stress relaxation test for the cyclic uh
if we just look at them separately in
the stress relaxation we have an
increase and then a gradual increase
during the whole time
right this gradual increase during the
whole time is itself kind of interesting
because your stress is decreasing a lot
but still you have an increase in in
fluorescence so it's a very cool time
dependent things happening inside the
structure
if we overlay the stress strain uh pots
of these two and monotonicated it
becomes very clear that overall the
cyclic stress is like much lower on
average than the stress relaxation
because every time you're going back to
zero stress
uh if we look at fluorescence we see the
cyclic actually has the strongest
response
so even though it has less stress over
time it the molecules on average feel
like way more stress
or right we're getting an aggregated
fluorescence that says like
stop stop shaking shaking
all right like it's it's feeling much
more that if I just like stay here and
hang out
I like why roller coasters are more
exciting than
not to me I hate roller coasters
more exciting than just just sitting at
the top of the
book great yeah
this [ __ ] was clearly they little uh
electrons in our lives
then actually we lost energy when
applied Spirit when you relax they
should have absorption energy from
somewhere
so there's
um
I'm going to separate out that question
and so like what's Just Happening
mechanically and what's happening in
terms of the of the light changing
molecule yeah so so when I pull out a
polymer and then I hold it there it's
dissipating energy that editor it's
becoming it's no longer stored but
category it's becoming thermal energy
and we test samples that are small
enough that it should be pretty easy for
that thermal energy to go into the
atmosphere the in terms of the
fluorescence we're we're exciting that
fluorescence with an excitation light so
um
this is not the light emitting system
yeah
exactly yeah so it's a little different
yeah there's there's a group that did a
similar
totally different but anyway similar set
of very mechanics oriented uh tests on
the light emitting system that also has
really cool findings but
I don't know I've already I'm sure maybe
way too many slides for the day
um yeah okay
so we wanted to um
try to have a cool paper and finish with
a demo
um and one thing that
um
that this material does is record
history of really plastic deformation I
don't think that quite so we'll do on
that but history of the stress that's
happened and so what we did was we ran
what's called a four point bending test
I like this test not as much as tension
testing of course uh but because you get
an area in the middle that's like a pure
moment and so you you have a compressive
strain on top no strain in the middle
and a tensile strain on the on the
bottom so it's it's kind of a cool
um
gradient of strains that you have happen
we looked at this uh test under using
Digital Image correlation which is a
technique that you use to image string
Fields so it lets you know that you have
compression on the top and tension on
the bottom and how much you have and
then we also use UV light to look at our
mechanical responsor to look at our our
equivalent of our fluorescence response
from before
I'll just show movies first and then
snapshots on the next so uh here's our
Digital Image population we're showing
screening Contours and then our our
fluorescence
so if we look at the strain data what we
see is
um when we let's start a load we have
lots of strain and then we we look at
our snapshot later and we've recovered
so
um I can see that something happened but
I don't really see how much happened
and so if you think about this like I
had an impact on my you know window in
my helicopter
right I I want to know how much happened
okay so in our meccano4 system we
actually get as much intensity in the
unloaded state
so this this keeps a record of like how
bad things were
so that's why we're excited about it
from uh application perspective
in addition to the studying polymers
perspective
let me ask this our metal coordination
bonds I think you can collectibility I
should just pre-asked Adrian so
it's a familiar unfamiliar
okay
also over many all over many biology
systems but probably more on the on the
animal side
um
I'll I'll just talk about our work in
this field but
um
this idea of metal coordination bonding
to control materials uh really started
by studying muscles not this kind
anymore uh the type that's in the ocean
so uh muscles in the ocean have like
really insane ability to dissipate
energy because
like there's an ocean and they're
attached to a rock and they want to stay
attached to the Rock
um and so there's sort of two parts of
that system both actually involve metal
coordination bonding the first is this
like really sticky
goo that helps it uh stay attached to
the Rock underwater and the second is
like if my arm could stretch like a
hundred times it's like then come all
the way back over time which I can't
demo that because I'm not in fact gummy
um
that's that's probably no one here that
was gonna be either all right so um
there is both both of those like
dissipation mechanisms are enabled by um
biological metal coordination bonding
and then uh material scientists were
like oh hey cool we can like do
something with that
um so I'm on that bandwagon uh this is
we're primarily done by my former
graduate student Joy Zhang and um we
worked uh with a group at Michigan that
does some really cool spectroscopy and a
Marine Science group at a Newcastle
University
and uh the little mini story I'm going
to tell about this is applying uh this
technique to pdms or silicone pdms is
used in a lot of applications partially
because it's easy to make
um partially because it is uh
bio-compatible
and so you'll see it in like
micropolitic devices you'll see it as a
place that people like grow cells and
then also um the world that I got
involved with is this Marine fouling
release coating so it's a pretty good
coating for not only for stopping things
from attaching but for letting things be
removed with relatively relative ease so
in the like World of the Navy
um right things grow on your boats
that's like a huge environmental impact
and fuel consumption also like spreading
spreading organisms across the ocean so
there's like a I don't know 30 plus year
program funded by a Office of Naval
Research on how to have things either
not attach or release easily
and so uh pdms has low surface energy
which is why it's used as a filing
release coating it's also a problem
because it tends to not adhere to
substrates wealth actually getting it
onto the coating is hard and usually if
they do like an extra surface treatment
uh it has really high hydrophobicity
which leads to absorption of various
proteins and um and this is uh probably
the thing that I'll focus on the most it
has this problem with surface
reconstruction so it's like a really
Dynamic at room temperature and the
polymer chains are always moving and so
people will try to like change the
surface like by putting an oxidation
coating on it but but like 20 minutes
later that okay maybe not 20 minutes but
on the scale of hours that coding is
gone because your service actually
reconstructed a new change around the
top
so our idea was that we could um
manipulate the Surface by manipulating
the bulk so instead of trying to just
change the surface properties we're just
going to change the properties
everywhere and let the attack actually
use the adaptivity to help ourselves and
so the way uh that we are doing this is
by hiding a polar functionality in the
material and specifically I'll talk
about our example of using metal
coordination bonding so
um I think of a metal coordination bond
is somewhere between ionic and
both balance so there's a little bit of
sharing but basically it's it's a
Charged interaction
um and it's got like huge tunability
which is another uh reason that it's
kind of fun to work with so it can be
really as strong as covalent bonds and
then like all the way pathetic like
Dynamic not lasting at all
um it's really environmentally sensitive
and so
um we were able to find some synthesis
procedures in literature that we were
able to use so uh basically we do is we
buy commercial pdms we buy short chains
so that things are very flexible
and then we tack on what's called a
ligand
and by Tech I mean use uh polymerization
technique so we use a chemistry
technique right to add that
functionality onto the end
and now we have something that could
bind the metal on both sides of a pretty
short chain of uh P of s
and then we we picked a metal center so
we have a divalent metal in the middle
and it in general is going to want to
interact with three of these polymer
canines and so we end up with a very
Dynamic Network where
um basically and any one of these comes
loose then the chain is free to move and
this this is uh this is the polymer
before the metal you can see it's it's
quite
not too viscous very liquid uh we also
made a setup a control system where we
instead of putting just a functionality
on both sides we use it to actually make
the chains longer so that with a much
longer polymer chain and functionalities
in the middle so this is
um much much less dynamic as a control
but it has the same amount of metal as
our other system so it's a good check of
whether it's just metal content
and I will skip most things I just want
to show off
um our control system is like much
stiffer than our dynamic system which is
all the way down here or blown up here
this is our dynamic system very stretchy
this is our control system
and
what we're able to do is actually
control contact angle through time and
so with our more dynamic system we start
out hydrophobic but our surface actually
reconstructs so it ends up hydrophilic
in a way that's uh fully reversible and
I'll show the movie version
so this is this is tailoring through
counter ions instead of through
um the metal but basically you can see
if we go with a really Dynamic
interaction we get a really quick
transformation and if we go with a less
Dynamic interaction we get almost no
transformation
which we applied to try to solve this
falling problem for which we were funded
we're funded hopefully again
um and uh this is where the
um Marine Group came in so they test
basically model organisms one of these
is a diatom
and you let them
um grow um settle and then grow on the
polymer and then you try to remove them
using shear stress in water and then you
see like how much is left this is one of
the organisms the other one is olowenzo
which is a soft macro color so it's
another model organism and we see that
our system is actually pretty good at
helping facilitate bowel release for
diatoms and um
really not good at all for our Valencia
um so still some work to do
but I think I'll
um
finish there so please email me if
you're interested in lme
um structure function relationships are
awesome and uh that's my group and
funding search so thank you
on your very last point
I don't know biologically why but I know
why these are the two model organisms
um so
diatoms tend to grow
well on
hydrophobic surfaces or stick weld
hydrophobic surfaces and oval lenses
tend to stick well to hydrophilic
surfaces
our Our Hope was that we would be
creating a dynamic surface where like
nothing would be happy but but we really
just made the oval of the happy and the
diapers unhappy so I guess we fall into
attract many people in this program
before us have fallen into
yeah
I don't know why I don't have the
biological understanding of why although
I was like
happy on hydrophilic
yeah it's a very nice tool so you should
um
information and also special
have you ever tried it on one of our
conversations about regions that are
more elastic but also have a little bit
more
foreign
yes let's see
actually as a as a sub
comment I do think if you do um like
smaller scale microscopy on this you
would actually see in provocative in
that classy but um one of the systems
we've done this on is
um actually that's why I was
post-docking we put it into
polyurethane which has domains that are
much more rigid and much soft and we
looked at the difference between how it
responded if it was in the soft and the
heart and some other groups have done
things like that so yeah you could
definitely use it to help understand
life stress distribution in different
types of domains within a polymer yeah
just
stress relaxation is
yeah cool because I picked this to show
which I haven't presented in a while
because I I think it'd be a cool way and
I'd excuse but thinking about that as
well over like cool way to look at
plants if we can figure out how to put
this or an equivalent molecule into a
biological concept so they're supposed
cool yeah I mean I think that would be
awesome Yes it comes with lots of
problems but I think it's worth it if it
makes any sense like you need to be very
careful about interpreting uh the
results because of this time dependence
aspect and the environment dependent
aspect of the temperature dependent
aspects but still I think we can gain
knowledge by doing it
is there any amount of Cyril Iran that's
converted into its active form we are
loading just in the elastic
they like good
repeated loadings within that elastic
the least result in an accumulation uh
got the signal
um
yes maybe so if I Define elastic phase
in the
I'll say like the way that we teach
undergrads elastic phase then yes
so um in the place where it looks linear
um if you
go far enough along that point and just
hold
it will eventually change color we did
we did some of those experiments um also
I guess that's when I was post talking
we ran with called creep experiments
where you hold it at constant force so
even though you're like at linear
elastic
you think you're a linear elastic you're
not really linear elastic so
um like in most glossy polymers you
actually always have some yielding
happening or some plastic deformation
happening and so I do think there's like
a not very detectable fraction of
fluorescence that's happening even
before we hit yield and there's some
like Taylor experiments you can run to
sort of capture that regime I do not
think that you would see a response in
the last in like truly in an elastic
regime here and the reason is not really
about Force
um it's about like Mobility or freedom
of those molecules to like even find a
space to change shape
so but if I put these molecules into a
rubber band-like material I don't I have
a basically a different set of design
rules so I'm not sampling the lack of
Freedom or the lack of space in the last
time around sampling like do I have
enough Force
yeah
um
there's a there's
okay so some people think of it as Force
like there's a critical Force for this
mechanical to react
but I think that's a misconception
so what you really have is a sort of a
more of a kinetics thing happening so as
you apply Force you are decreasing an
energy barrier and so your your attempts
like you're basically you're
you're rate of converting goes up and
people have done really nice systematic
studies on single polymer chains like
using that the molecule that has lots of
mechanical pores in it and been able to
really get at the rate dependence part
of it
so it's you shouldn't you should think
of it as a force accelerated reaction
rather than a critical Force threshold
yeah I'll send it to you later yeah
[Music]
in other words about polymers that
evolved of organisms
it's from the analyze
or going up to something like a larger
public cellular lawn pictures big
structure and puts up with wave actions
I
I have not I think that would be really
interesting
um the way that I up until let's say a
year ago the way that I interacted with
Biology is by like stumbling into
mechanics people's talks about that
involve biology or inspired by biology
um so this is definitely this is a new a
new boot for me where I'm like actually
trying to learn but yeah
yeah I
I think one um maybe along those lines
like one one thing that's interesting
about this this metal coordination
bonding concept is most of those
organisms actually are sea based
organisms so I talked about the muscle
Bissell threads there's also like a
really awesome worm jaw thing where it
like has goes from very compliant to
like insanely stiff by uh concentration
of different types of metal cations and
also a structural organization so and I
do think like why are they using metal
alliances because they're in a green
environment and that's something they
have access to so I do think
it would be really interesting I just I
haven't done it yeah
the cool perspective to take on it
they're really really cool review for
coming
thanks
okay great yeah
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu